Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 14. We're going to concentrate
here, in this video, on confirmation
indicators. Now, confirmation indicators
are what they say they are. We use them as
professional traders to either confirm or
deny what we were thinking previously, 6
to 12 months before we did.
they come out. Because 6 to 12 months
before, we're looking at the leading
indicators and trying to predict the
future as traders and using the market at
that point in time as a proxy for our
views. So we either buy or short or in our
portfolio have a market neutral exposure
at that point in time. And then at some
point in the future, 6, 12 months down the
line, we have what we call confirmation
indicators.
These confirmation indicators are made up
by coincident and lagging indicators.
Coincident indicators are telling us
what's happening in the economy as a whole
at this moment in time. As in, right now,
in the present, or for example, around the
present, so maybe in the last 3 or 4
weeks.
Now, the one I want you to focus on the
most here is the employment situation
report. Because the employment situation
report contains the non-farm payroll
number, as in the amount of jobs added in
the last 4 weeks in the United States. And
this serves as a classic example.
The non-farm payroll number is the
non-farm payroll number. The non-farm
payroll number is a coincident indicator.
It tells us what's happening now in the US
economy to jobs. And it serves as a really
good example because amateur and retail
traders base their trading decisions on a
very short-term basis on the non-farm
payroll number.
And this misses the whole point because,
and for amateur and retail traders, this
is the biggest mistake because they're
using an indicator which is telling them
what's happening now where the
professional trading community has been
told for months before that this is going
to be the situation in the non-farm
payroll number.
In the non-farm payroll number. And in the
employment situation in the United States.
As in, if the health of the US economy is
set to improve, then clearly 6 to 12
months down the line, there's going to be
more jobs added.
And if it's going to deteriorate, clearly
6 to 12 months down the line, there's
going to be a net negative effect on jobs
in the United States.
And by the time the non-farm payroll
number comes out, all professional traders
really know that the situation is either
going to improve or deteriorate.
And economists base their estimates in
non-farm payrolls on the leading
indicators from 6 to 12 months before, but
also on initial and continuing claims in
the four weeks leading up to the non-farm
payroll number.
So what actually happens is by the time
the non-farm payroll number comes out, all
that's happening is the amateur and the
retail traders who always lose money are
the guys who are offering the liquidity on
the other side for professional traders to
trade out of their positions because
they've predicted this previously.
Now, concentrate on the non-farm payroll,
it's a confirmation indicator. As a
professional trader, it confirms or denies
your views that you hold already.
So for example, if you think the world is
in really good shape and you believe from
the leading indicators that the world,
that US GDP is going to expand, you will
be thinking that the non-farm payroll
number is always going to increase and
potentially increase.
Now what happens if it doesn't? Well, that
denies that your view was correct. So you
may have to change your view, but very
rarely does this happen. So let's go over
to the presentation. Make sure you see
confirmation indicators for what they are.
Again, try not to listen to the noise in
the market because every day, every week,
every month, you're going to be told by
the populist media that this number is
really important, you should be focusing
on this.
A lot of it is just irrelevant. And what
we've looked at so far with the leading
indicators is the 3% of information that
is really relevant and is going to make
you money.
And what you've got to do is take that,
interpret it and turn it into real
dollars. But along the way, you should be
diligent, not lazy, be diligent to
actually look at the confirmation
indicators and make sure that your views
are either correct or if they're wrong, do
something about it.
Okay, so let's go over to the presentation
and I'll see you on the other side.
Okay, let's go through confirmation
indicators. So indicators that come out
each month that confirm or deny our views.
So the first one we'll look at is the
employment situation report. That's where
we get non-farm payrolls and the
unemployment rate.
Second one we'll look at is US durable
goods and shipments. Third, industrial
production. They're all coincidence
indicators.
They tell you what's happening in the
economy now. So what's in the employment
situation report? What's non-farm
payrolls?
Anybody know what non-farm payrolls are?
It's the number of jobs added in the US
economy in the last month, essentially.
So everyone focuses on really the two main
numbers, the unemployment rate and total
non-farm payrolls.
That's where you get it there. It comes
out. How often does the non-farm payrolls
number come out? Anybody know?
It comes out every month in the employment
situation report. It tells you what
happened in the previous month in terms of
how many jobs were added in the United
States.
But there's something that we see every
single week that is another coincidence
indicator, which actually tells us what's
going to be in the non-farm payrolls.
Anybody know what it is?
Initial and continuing claims. Jobless
claims. You heard of that one? That's a
weekly number for the previous week.
What is that actually telling you? It's
telling you how many people are added in
the last week who claim unemployment
insurance benefit.
So you add up the four weeks and it should
give you a good idea of what the non-farm
payroll number is going to be.
And what happens? All the economists that
predict the non-farm payrolls number, they
don't change their estimates because
they're lazy.
But all the traders know roughly what it's
going to be.
So by the time it comes out, even if it
beats or misses, the number's old.
It's already pretty much priced into the
market.
Not just for that reason, but because you
would have known this anyway six months
previously or 12 months previously in the
leading indicators.
So what do all day traders do? Day traders
focus on the non-farm payrolls number and
if it misses big or beats big, they're
trying to buy or sell the market on that
day.
They're all late to the party. They've
missed all the big opportunity because
they've missed the leading indicators 12
months before, six months before.
And they haven't been watching the initial
and continuing jobless claims and figuring
out that 150,000 jobs added in the last
month in the US economy was consensus by
the economists.
But the economists' consensus estimates
are old and they haven't updated them.
And then the numbers reported as 200,000
and it doesn't matter because continuing
claims and initial claims were going down
for the last four weeks, which means it
was going to beat.
So we all know it's going to beat.
So we used to have a fantastic saying at
Goldman on the non-farm payrolls, the
first move is the wrong move.
So whatever the move is for the first five
minutes in the market after the non-farm
payrolls, it's the first move is the wrong
move.
So everybody's reacting to it, but they're
late.
So you take the other side, provides you
with liquidity to get out.
Make sense?
That's total non-farm payrolls with a
long-term trend.
Change in non-farm payrolls.
So that's the number we look at each
month.
So you got on the left-hand side there,
50,000, 100,000, 150,000.
How many jobs are added or taken away from
the US economy?
Pretty simple number.
How do you look at it?
Well, long-term trend of the US market,
long-term growth trend, 3%.
How many jobs, 3% GDP growth.
How many jobs does the US economy have to
add each month to run at 3% GDP growth?
Well, historically, it has to be over at
least a quarter of a million, if not over
300,000.
So we get a picture of what's happened in
the last few years immediately, without
looking at it.
If we know that, then if the US economy is
growing up between 1% and 2%, jobs are
being added, but a lot less than long-term
trend.
So what have we been getting?
We've been getting jobs added of between
75,000 and 150,000 typically over the last
three years.
So the unemployment rate has been coming
down, but it's been coming down very, very
slowly.
Total private employment, change in
private employment.
And you can see by looking at that chart
and the change in total non-farm payrolls,
that since the 50s, in business cycles,
when, in the part of the business cycle
when the economy is expanding,
over a number of decades, less jobs have
been added.
So much, much longer term on a big picture
trend, there could be structural issues in
the US labour market.
And that tells you the story there in the
private sector of the United States.
So for example, let's take, so this is
from the early 90s.
So in the 90s, when the US economy was
growing at an average trend of 3%, what
was happening?
250 to 400,000 jobs added per month.
In the noughties, 150 to 300,000 jobs
added per month.
Now, around 100.
100 to 150.
That's pretty much what we've been
getting.
So over the long, over the very long term,
in the last three business cycles, what's
occurred, relative to each other, is that
less jobs are created in the US economy,
each business cycle that we go through.
What you're looking at there is a picture
of regulation, because if you regulate
labour markets, that's what happens.
We're talking stuff like minimum wage,
yeah?
That's what happens when you regulate
labour markets.
That's government employment.
That's the unemployment rate.
So private sector is the most important.
What's happening with the US government
now?
What about jobs added at the US government
level?
Do we expect there's going to be lots of
new jobs created in the public sector in
the US?
There's lots of cuts.
So what you're seeing at the moment is the
private sector paying for the public
sector to exist.
So you might get 300,000 jobs added in the
private sector, but you'll get 100 taken
away in the government sector.
So total non-farm payrolls is 200.
That's the trend at the moment.
That's what's happening everywhere.
So the employment situation report gives
you a snapshot and really confirms or
denies what you were thinking 6 to 12
months previously.
You know, if you're expecting GDP to grow,
you're expecting non-farm payrolls to be
positive.
And you can kind of guess what rate it's
going to be at.
You know, give or take 50, 100,000.
Yeah?
So you're trying to predict what's going
to happen in the future.
And what you'll see in the ISM
manufacturing report, in the
non-manufacturing report,
you'll see the businesses reporting that
they're going to start employing people.
Because you've got the employment area of
each report.
Are you planning to hire more people?
And if it's above 50 for 12 months in a
row,
the non-farm payrolls number is going to
be positive and going to be up.
And then it confirms or denies what you've
already been told by the leading
indicators.
Initial and continuing claims.
So when someone in the US is made
unemployed, what happens?
They claim on their unemployment
insurance.
That statistic gets reported to the Labor
of Bureau statistics and they report it
every week.
For the previous week.
So by the time the non-farm payrolls
number comes out for the private sector or
the government sector or both,
it's pretty much known from weekly jobless
claims.
They're out every Thursday.
That's initial claims.
2,000 to present.
That's with a long-term trend in
continuing claims.
So what does that tell you?
Continuing claims, what's the definition?
It's basically long-term unemployment.
What's the trend?
What's the trend since the 60s?
Yeah.
Long-term, but it's an absolute number.
Don't forget the population's increased.
So it'd be better to put a percentage on
it, but it's still trending up as a
percentage as well.
It tells you that long-term structural
unemployment in the US is on a long-term
uptrend.
So you'll get this as well.
You'll get the ESR and jobless claims in
spreadsheets.
What's the ESR useful for?
Confirming or denying the leading
indicator data.
Confirming or denying weekly jobless
claims data.
Gauging the future pulse of consumers and
politicians.
Because jobs are a politically sensitive
issue.
So if all the leading indicators are doing
well, and the government's not doing
anything, but the unemployment rate isn't
coming down, you can guess that there's
going to be heat coming on the US
government to do something about the
unemployment rate coming down.
They're going to have to do something.
And consumers, what you're looking at
there is the propensity to spend money as
well.
So consumer sentiment will be positive the
more jobs that are added to the US
economy.
People will feel good about their future
prospects.
Confirming or denying your view on US GDP.
And therefore, confirming or denying a
world view.
Durable goods and shipments.
Coincidence indicator.
85 industries in one sample.
But they are big, multinational companies
with big, capital-intensive products.
It's the inputs of capital within the
manufacturing industry.
So when companies are making significant
investments in big-ticket items, as in,
they're going to create a new factory,
they're going to demand big, bulky, heavy
machinery, etc.
So, the durable goods orders report and
the shipments of those goods tell you
what's happened in the last month in those
industries.
If people are making highly
capital-intensive investments.
Yeah?
If the businesses themselves are doing it.
That should follow the ISM.
So that's it there.
In the green.
And what you usually get is total new
orders.
And then they strip out sectors which are
extremely sensitive to making the report
non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, they are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, you can make the report
non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, there are going to make
the report non-accurate.
In the green.
And what you usually get, is total new
orders.
And then, they strip out sectors which are
extremely sensitive to making the report
non-accurate.
So, if there's, sometimes you get, in the
transport sector, and in the defence
sector, one or two massive orders that
could skew the number.
They, they do it with a stripped out
number as well, for transport and defence.
So, for example, in the aerospace industry
in the last month, what do you think has
happened?
What do you think has happened in the last
month in the, in the US aerospace
industry?
What are, what are, what are they cutting
at government level at the moment?
Defence spending.
So, just one cut in defence spending can
have a massive impact on this number.
So, they strip it out.
And they strip out transport as well.
Just so you can see the number.
So, what you'll see in company, I mean,
you'll see the reports of companies like,
for example, you know, with defence
included, the impact that one order at
Boeing might have on the durable goods and
shipments orders.
Yeah?
And then you can strip out Boeing's order
of 20 planes and then you get a better
representation of everything in the US
economy.
Yeah?
That's what they do basically.
But you'll get the spreadsheet, go through
it, go on the internet, Google it.
It's all public information.
Learn about the durable goods report.
It's there to confirm or deny what you've
seen 12 months previously in the
manufacturing data in the leading
indicators.
Yeah?
So, confirming or denying PMI data.
Confirming or denying US GDP.
Confirming or denying your world view.
Industrial production.
Another coincidence indicator.
Gets reported with capacity utilisation.
And it's showing changes month on month,
year on year, in the business cycle, but
what's happening right now.
So, it follows the ISM.
That's what it looks like at an aggregate
level.
And that's what it looks like with all its
components.
So, it can actually give you a good idea
of what's happening in various industries.
For example, mining, materials, business
equipment, consumer goods.
It tells you what's going on right now.
You'll get the spreadsheet.
Check it out.
Go through the history.
Learn it yourself.
Go on Google.
Play around with the data.
Have a look at the report.
Have a look at multiple reports on the
internet.
It's all publicly available.
It's how you treat the information that's
as important.
So, it confirms or denies.
Confirming or denying PMI data.
Confirming or denying your view on US GDP.
And your world view.
Okay, welcome back.
What you saw there being presented was the
confirmation indicators.
In the United States.
They are the main ones that you'll see
reported every month.
So, let's do a quick summary.
What we saw was the employment situation
report.
Which includes the non-farm payrolls
number and the unemployment rate.
We also looked at weekly initial and
continuing jobless claims.
So, these come out on a weekly basis and
you should be on top of them.
We also saw the durable goods number.
And the durable goods number is really
tracking the big ticket items in the
United States.
That's a coincidence indicator as well.
And we also saw industrial production.
Now, the way you look at all these.
Again, they're confirmation indicators and
you need to see them for what they are.
They are all coincident indicators.
In that they tell us what's happening in
the economy overall at this moment in
time.
So, running through them.
Employment situation report.
Non-farm payrolls included with the
unemployment rate and initial and
continuing claims on a weekly basis.
Take those all together because what ends
up being in the non-farm payrolls number
really starts off in the weekly initial
and continuing claims.
Now, when you look at the non-farm
payrolls number, this is one of the most
favorite numbers amongst the day trading
community.
Because it creates volatility on the day.
However, the big money is not made there.
A lot of the time, the first move is the
wrong move.
In fact, that's a big saying in the
market.
Simply because we've been told for weeks
already, pretty much, that economists'
estimates are probably wrong.
And economists are slow to change their
estimates.
So, whenever there's a beat or a miss and
you get the first move in non-farm
payrolls, pretty much most of the time
it's the wrong move.
Because it's already expected.
And then the day traders are basically
giving the guys who have predicted it
liquidity to get out of their positions.
So, the employment situation report,
including the non-farm payrolls and
unemployment rate, along with weekly
initial and continuing claims, is
important because it confirms or denies
your views that you held at that time but
you made months before.
So, why they're also important is because
jobs is a politically sensitive issue in
the United States and also all over the
world.
So, it can actually predict if there's big
problems in the jobs sector, in the jobs
numbers.
It can predict future government behaviour
and also consumers may actually start to
react to very bad or very good jobs data
simply because it's in the mainstream
media.
But if it's kind of here nor there and
it's always meeting expectations, you
won't see material changes in government
policy or in consumer sentiment and
behaviour.
Moving on to durable goods.
Durable goods are big ticket items.
All the spreadsheets are there and you
should download the spreadsheets next to
the video and have a look at the numbers
in the durable goods spreadsheets because
occasionally you do have to read the
numbers by stripping out the big ticket
situations such as transport and aerospace
and defence.
Because one order can move the entire
number, the composite number of durable
goods.
So, sometimes splitting out these numbers
is good and when you do this on a monthly
basis and you go through the numbers and
put them in your spreadsheets, you'll see
what we mean.
This is just something you have to get
used to doing.
And the final number, industrial
production, really when you look at
durable goods and industrial production as
coincidence indicators, what are they
telling us?
Well, they're confirming or denying the
views that we obtained as professional
traders months before in the manufacturing
PMI.
So, when the industrial production number
and durable goods number comes out, it's
an extension of what we already believe in
the PMIs, in the manufacturing PMI as in
the ISM.
So, what you see in the ISM in January,
for example, will probably start happening
in 6 months to 12 months time, so between
June and December in the same year.
So, see these things for what they are,
they're confirmation indicators.
Do not, whatever you do, make the mistake
as a retail trader, which is the real
amateur mistake, by seeing a confirmation
indicator and making a trading decision
based on it.
As in, you see a good non-farm payrolls
number, so you go and buy the S&P 500 or
you go and buy your favourite stock in the
S&P 500.
That's just really amateur and it's just
going to get you in trouble because the
non-farm payrolls number has been
predicted 9 times out of 10.
So, just see them for what they are, see
your confirmation indicators as something
that confirms or denies the views that you
already have.
Because at any one point in time, you're
going to be holding a portfolio that
represents your views.
And the vast majority of times, what
you're probably going to see is that the
numbers in confirmation indicators, in the
coincident indicators, in the vast
majority of cases, are actually going to
confirm what you already believe.
Okay, now we're going to move on from
confirmation indicators, and we've covered
leading indicators in the US, so now what
we've got is an entire repertoire, a suite
of indicators that predict US GDP that we
can use to take positions in the S&P 500
with.
So, now what we're going to do is try and
create, try and get a real perspective of
global GDP.
So, now we're going to take the same
principles that we've established in the
US leading indicators and move those
principles over to Europe and into China.
So, what we're going to see is indicators,
leading indicators in Europe and in China
are actually very similar to the United
States.
They're designed in a very similar way, so
that makes our life very easy.
So, we're going to go over to Europe now,
and we're going to look at the Eurozone in
its entirety in video number 15.
So, I'll see you on the other side, see
you in the next video.
Thank you.